this video is sponsored by the great
courses plus
there are trillions and trillions of
cells inside us that build us into who
we are
all made up of the same building blocks
of matter that comprise everything else
in the universe
and yet there appears to be something
very different in us
something unfathomably distinct from the
countless other arrangements of matter
this seemingly singular thing is the
only thing that lets us know that there
are
any other things or an in or an out or
an
us at all and without it all things
seem to disappear this is of course
consciousness
despite consciousness being so
unavoidably essential to everything that
we know
and experience and despite it feeling so
intuitive and obvious
consciousness remains one of humanity's
greatest unsolved mysteries
unlike most if not all other mysteries
though consciousness is the only mystery
that is
in us or perhaps more accurately is us
or at least what feels like us it is the
closest
most obvious thing to us all and yet one
of the furthest from our understanding
ever since the concept of consciousness
entered the vernacular of consciousness
itself
and surely beyond that individuals of
all sorts have attempted to put
explanations to the strange feeling
of being something that knows that it
knows what being something feels like
religious figures scientists
philosophers
and everyone in between and although
there have been substantial improvements
in knowledge of the brain
and various theories of mind we still
have yet to really get much closer
to knowing what is truly behind the
magic show of consciousness
if anything the only thing that's been
revealed is that we have mostly been
looking in the wrong places
misdirected by the illusionist that is
our own mind
what we can say we know about
consciousness is sort of what we all
already know
intuitively consciousness is this right
now
it is what allows us to be aware of some
portion of our external surroundings
and internal states and in our complex
human case
it is what gives us our likely illusory
but no less strong
sense of an inner eye a director of
rational reflection
focus and comprehension this might seem
obvious
but that really just speaks to the point
of how little we actually
know put slightly more eloquently
philosopher thomas nagel says that
something is conscious
if it can be said that it is like
something to be that something
as in there is an experience had in
slightly different more specific terms
philosopher daniel dennett once said
that consciousness is like how the user
interface on the screen of a smartphone
works
like the phone screen is just displaying
the results of a massive complex
layering of electrical components
working in the background consciousness
is the display screen or user interface
of the brain
which results from the complex system of
neural subfunctions
happening in the background although
this seems simple enough there still
remains a deeply mysterious problem here
in the same way let's say the youtube
app cannot be pinpointed in the
electrical firings of the computer chips
of a smartphone
and essentially does not exist without
the screen the experience of the events
and consciousness
cannot seem to be pinpointed in the
relevant specific form
anywhere else in the brain other than
one's personal conscious experience of
them
in other words to understand the
hardware or brain activity
serves only slight purpose to
understanding consciousness
since only when the screen of
consciousness is on and lit
does anything in the hardware equate to
anything experiential
thus the perception of the screen has to
be accounted for
in order to define or understand
conscious phenomena
but yet this component seems exclusively
subjective
and hidden from anything outside the
experiencer
as a result there are many scientists
and philosophers who believe that the
nature of consciousness
simply cannot and will not ever be
understood at least not in any complete
sense
or at least not by us that at best
it is a puzzle that even if fully put
together will only reveal an image that
doesn't really
look like anything to go to the opposite
direction of the spectrum
religious types might suggest that the
source of consciousness is already known
be it that of some sort of soul or along
a similar train of thought
some argue for a theory of mind known as
dualism
most commonly attributed to 17th century
philosopher rene descartes
which argues that the mind or
consciousness and the brain
are two distinctly separate things in
which the brain doesn't create
consciousness
but acts as a sort of connection point
between the physical body
and some other worldly non-physical
supernatural-like mental substance
that interacts with it however for the
most part and for good reasons
dualism along with all other
supernatural explanations of
consciousness
are mostly discounted and not taken
seriously by many of today's leading
thinkers
as a means of simply illustrating why
this sort of non-physical
supernatural explanation doesn't work
consider the following question
can something with no physical
attributes affect something that does
have physical attributes
in simpler terms can nothing make
something move
can a ghost both walk through walls and
pick something physical
up logically it cannot do both
as an example in the case of the mind
let's say odorous molecules from
fresh-cut grass
enter into a person's nose and since
these molecules have physical properties
they bind with a specific set of
olfactory receptors
located in the upper part of the nasal
cavity this binding then generates and
sends an electrical signal to the brain
also with physical properties causing
the person to experience the smell of
grass
inciting an associated state of mind
perhaps a pleasurable nostalgia for
spring
this then might cause them to physically
react in a certain way
like smile or inhale deeply this however
would require
another physical signal to be sent from
the mind to the parts of the brain and
body
that move the nose and mouth but if
consciousness is immaterial
with no physical attributes how does it
send this signal
how does the conscious experience of
pleasure and nostalgia
caused the physical brain and body to
move and smile
this simply would not agree with what we
know to be true
as a result it is now most commonly
believed in science
that consciousness is like all other
phenomena something that is to be
considered from a naturalistic and
physicalist view
which argues that all things including
the brain and mind
or consciousness are made of matter with
physical properties
all of which are part of the natural
world and thus restricted to the same
laws of physics that govern everything
else
the remaining problem here though and
why it's not so simple
returns to the smartphone analogy in the
same way that knowing how the inside
mechanics of a smartphone work
would still leave someone with mostly
nothing as a measure of understanding
what a smartphone
is actually like to use if they had
never used one with a screen on it
so too does the use of objective
physical terms
to define consciousness leave out the
essential subjective experience of it
to say for example ex-physical
interaction in the brain is happiness
neglects the fact that it isn't
happiness is the feeling of happiness
not the objective physical
representation and so
even if specific physical events could
be pinpointed sufficiently to specific
conscious experiences
it still wouldn't seem to make any sense
as to how
how does the same basic non-sentient
stuff that makes rocks
and water and trees and worms the same
building blocks of everything else that
isn't aware of itself
somehow come together in such a way
inside you and
suddenly out of what seems like almost
nothing become your entire ornate
awareness and experience of self and
life how does it become the feeling of
happiness and wonder and romance and
melancholy
and the experience of colors and
imagined intricate scenes that only
exist inside your head
with no correlating source this
overwhelming perplexing sticking point
is known as the heart problem of
consciousness a term coined by the
philosopher david chalmers in 1995.
in the words of thomas nagle if we
acknowledge that a physical theory of
mind
must account for the subjective
character of experience
we must admit that no presently
available conception
gives us a clue how this could be done
the problem
is unique one other alternative theory
worth mentioning
is the idea that consciousness could be
a fundamental property of all
reality this is argued for by the
philosophy known as pan psychism
which generally suggests that all things
in the universe have a mind-like quality
to them
and all physical systems in a very loose
sense feel like something to be
that system it then follows in this
theory that there must be a potential
conscious quality
in everything although counter-intuitive
and rather absurd sounding
this could still exist coherently within
the bounds of scientific and rational
understanding
and not throw out any of the current
frameworks of physics
however even if this is true it still
doesn't necessarily answer the question
of how to define or understand
consciousness outside of the
individually subjective experience
which returns to the same relative
problem
ultimately there really only seems to be
two options
either the paste in our head creates
this whole thing or some ethereal
transmission from some other worldly
dimension
and both can only be described as
unfathomably insane
a miracle in its truest sense to be a
thing that knows it's a thing
and furthermore knows that it knows it's
a thing
matter that knows what matter is matter
that can look out at all sorts of other
arrangements of matter
that have no idea what they are or
aren't and give names and attribute
feelings to these
things to feel pain and pleasure and
love and happiness and all the rest
to experience even if just for a time
this immense kaleidoscope of physical
reality from the distinct and temporary
home
that is your head if the rest of the
universe's matter could look back at us
one can only assume it would cry with
jealousy
like the concepts of infinity or true
nothingness
like the cosmic questions why is there
something instead of nothing
or how did everything start out of
nothing
consciousness finds itself in the arena
of humanity's tightest sealed remaining
mysteries
only this particular mystery this
particular miracle of impossible
dissonance
is you and because of this you are the
only one who will ever know what it is
actually like
nothing will ever reveal your
consciousness your experience of blue
and love and pain and so on to anyone
else
for all eternity and it is arguably the
one thing that cannot be doubted
nothing else can be known for sure with
certainty but because you think
you are and because you understand you
are some form of consciousness
it is the one thing you can always know
to be true and forever
exclusively your own your one
single experience of everything
[Music]
this video was sponsored by the great
courses plus
throughout life our interests and
curiosities can change quite often and
with increasing degrees of depth
this is great of course but sustaining
lifelong learning can often be
challenging and time-consuming
the great courses plus is an on-demand
video learning platform that makes this
much easier
a subscription to the great courses plus
provides you with unlimited access to a
growing library of over 11 000
high-level in-depth video lectures
covering a wide variety of subjects in
areas like psychology
philosophy science literature history
arts and much more the courses are
created and taught by professors from
ivy leagues
and top universities around the world as
well as experts from places like
national geographic
allowing you to learn on your own terms
without compromising quality
and depth if you're interested in
learning more about different topics
related to the mind
there are several great courses one in
particular entitled
being human life lessons from the
frontiers of science
which goes into a variety of topics
related to the evolutionary origins of
different human behavior
and the ways in which these behaviors
and mental experiences
are both affected and manifested in
modern day life
if you're interested you can start your
free trial today by visiting
thegreatcoursesplus.com
pursuit of wonder or by clicking the
link in the description below
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general and see you next
[Music]
video
you